Alicia is announcing today do you want
to make the announcement you want me to
say I would like to see how you were
it's really weird because I felt I
wouldn't because I'm so strong in my
conviction here it is Nikki's like do
you think it's what it's a sex change
Ronnie sure looks familiar because of
what's between my legs
Lisa and I was shocked and that feelings
about this Lisa is retiring from
stand-up comedy she will no longer
perform this is she performs her last
stand-up set in June yep yep you got
aggravated with the audio well no that
wasn't why I'm retiring I decided to
retire from stand-up about two three
years ago when my father was sick about
six years ago before his death I was
like you know what I really loved
helping him I loved helping people and
pretty soon those five years of comedy
started feeling like the message is
getting lost the message of including
people threw insults is getting lost and
now maybe god forbid I'm being
misunderstood by different races
transgender people gay people even
though I have love in my heart and I
said you know what I want to do
something that has a clear message to
make people feel better about themselves
so now what I feel is I have these
connections through storytelling events
through workshops I'm giving about food
and body image that I feel like wow
that's what it feels like so today when
you roast Ronnie time you will be mean
to my friends and family I'll still call
them concept right